power rankings for week four which
begins tomorrow night with two of the
worst teams in the nfl the broncos and
the jets let's focus on the top for now
though and it was the showdown and last
week there was a question from
christopher sims did you consider making
the ravens number one over the chiefs i
said the ravens have to beat the kings
of the hill before they get to the top
of the hill they had their chance it
didn't work and there are consequences
just like elections have consequences
football games have consequences the
ravens drop down four spots by virtue of
losing to the chiefs and let me start
there chris yeah do you agree with me
putting the ravens behind the seahawks
the patriots and the other two teams the
graphic went away and i can't remember
who they are but they are behind four
teams now in addition to the team they
lost to on monday night uh no i don't
agree with you there i don't i i would
have still i would have probably moved
them to either that three or four
position i can understand you having new
england where they are
uh yes but no i i think ultimately i
probably would have had the ravens at
three at this point you know just no
it's a tough matchup they played a
special player caught him on a bad night
all that but man and just the ravens i
still i'm not panicked about them as a
football team am i a little like
concerned about
can they win enough games in the
playoffs this way yeah a little bit um
but i think you went a little low with
him i just don't think i could take the
bills and a pat and the bills and the
packers and straight up match up with
the ravens right now i don't think i
could do that
yeah but i feel differently about the
ravens after what i saw yeah that's fine
that's you're right they didn't keep it
as close as we thought it was going to
be right and i think part of it too is
when you've gotten yourself excited for
a great game
and the game doesn't deliver you got to
take out your frustration on somebody
you can't take it out on the team that
won yeah so you take it out on the team
that lost right how dare you do that how
dare you not entertain us
we were not entertained you ruined
monday night you're banished to number
six on the power rankings i mean i i
would admit i'm willing to admit it that
was part of the thinking i was pissed
off that the ravens didn't give us the
game that we were thinking we were gonna
get i get you i i hear you and you know
you probably could frame that to part of
your argument that when they seem to
play teams that are just equal to them
or that way that you know there's
certainly questions there so you know i
get it i understand what you're saying
it was it was unimpressive looking and
you know to what we said yesterday 34 20
no
no i mean really that game was 44 to 10
it might have been 51 to 10. i don't
know what it was that's really the way
the game looked on the field let me ask
you this just about one and two how
significant or how big is the gap
between chiefs at one and seahawks two
for you right now
oh boy i'd love to find out in february
i hope you're pretty you know even
though i you're so mad you didn't pick
that right you're just like that was so
obvious and i didn't pick it and i don't
know why i really thought of you on that
one i just i i did i went with my gut
feeling yeah i i just i went i because i
know here's the thing even if you get
that right nobody cares and and if you
go too far outside the box yeah you can
never live it down i remember there was
a year where i thought okay here's what
happens
one team that makes it to the super bowl
is the team we expected the other team
often is a team that we weren't really
thinking about so i just i remember it
was washington i said they're gonna make
it to the super bowl this year and of
course they weren't very good and and it
took several years before people would
leave me alone about that so it makes
sense to stay within the buoys of
reasonableness but there is a chance
someone's going to rise up but for now
yeah i wish they played in the regular
season and i'd love to see the chiefs
and the seahawks on the same field and
it's making me root
for if it can't be my buccaneers
patriots matchup i'm rooting for the
seahawks and the chiefs because that
would be a hell of a game oh and i wish
they could play this week right yeah i i
hear you it would it would be a hell of
a game it i mean i don't know but the
scoreboard might blow up in that one it
would be so fun to watch
right where do you want to go all right
i got an issue we've got steelers at
nine you should have them in front of
the titans and buccaneers
i don't i i i just was the steelers
defense is super bowl caliber i know
they haven't like played the best games
yet like but they haven't their teams
their three opponents are all winless i
i get that
they've they've let teams hang around
well they didn't let the texans hang
around they had to come back and beat
the texans but their opponents haven't
won a game no i i know i know but you
know i i still would look at them just
to go with the buccaneers who have
played the broncos and the jaguars and a
saints team that we're not that sure
about and i'd gonna i feel more
comfortable with the steelers over the
titans and the bucks right now not that
it's like by a landslide i'm just just
telling you where i am i i get where you
are there i get it the steelers have not
like dominated a team from start to
finish yet
bucks have beaten the panthers and the
broncos not the jaguars oh sorry yeah
one of those cats 1995. one of those
teams that they're that vague they're
always connected because for those of us
who have been paying attention to
football for a long time they entered
the nfl at the same time in 1995 so even
there is no other connection between
those two teams the fact that just like
the bucks and the seahawks two teams
it's happened twice in my lifetime well
since i've been paying attention to
football where teams have entered the
league the bucks and the seahawks and
the jaguars and the panthers so anyway
the bucks okay
i've got them at number eight now the
saints who beat tampa bay week one are
at number 10 after losing to the packers
do we think now there's a one game lead
right now for tampa bay over new orleans
they get a rematch coming up later in
the year at tampa bay are the buccaneers
ahead of the saints right now in your
mind as the favorites to win the nfc
south no not yet but i do like what
you're kind of seeing develop in that
you know buccaneers football team i want
to take a closer look at that broncos
game and kind of really watch it on
coach's film i kind of just watched the
tv version back just to get a feel for
the game but you know again brady looked
as comfortable as i've seen him look so
far just from that you know tv glance uh
on sunday and what he did and again i
thought the offense too for the second
week in a row had a lot of his
handprints on it definitely and then i
think the most encouraging thing with
the bucks is
they have an overwhelming front at times
and their defense seems like it's
getting it together we knew they were
dominated up front i think it was about
the secondary that's where i just want
to see it a little bit
because they haven't played you know an
offense that's really aggressive and can
push the ball down the field quite yet
or anything like that but i i mean they
have some pieces where you certainly got
to recognize them and go whoa and it
does seem like it's slowly but surely
coming together for them
you know i dropped the 49ers out of the
top 10 all the way to number 13 after
beating the jets 31-13 because of all
the injuries because jimmy garoppolo was
out nick bose has done for the year
solomon thomas done for the year yeah 11
guys uh unavailable starters unavailable
for the game against the giants and then
they go out and they destroy the giants
dismantle the giants and now the 49ers
creeping their way back up they're two
in one
they are in the mix in the nfc west and
definitely in the mix for a wild card
berth
how long will it work with nick mullins
is this something that's sustainable
until jimmy garoppolo can come back and
do they have a situation where they
could apply the
the time-honored 100 percent role to
jimmy garoppolo where kyle shanahan
decides jimmy g's on the sidelines until
he's 100
and he's not 100
until nick mullins
loses his magic well this will be a
different test this week i mean the
eagles defense has been you know giving
some teams some headaches so it's not
going to be the giants where they're
clearly the better team on the football
field and you know playing some team
that's rebuilding but i have no concerns
about nick mullins i mean really i have
no concerns about nick mullins one he
got to play extended periods of time two
years ago did well made some stupid you
know young quarterback mistakes but
still had some games and some moments
where we went whoa i mean he's doing
some special things here and even in
that same year cj beathard did some of
that so what my point is
uh you know shanahan's gonna get people
open and move the football he is a
genius that way he is going to crack the
code almost weekly in the nfl to some
extent you know last week he cracked it
through his drop back pass game oh you
want to take away the run game and do
all that okay cool all right well here
now i got something for you here and
mullins you know slowly but surely
started to pick apart that defense um i
do think they can make it work and as
they slowly get more healthy here i
think they'll continue to climb your
power rankings and we've talked about
their favorable schedule works out for
them they certainly can beat the eagles
this week with nick mullens there's no
doubt about that but i'm not ready to
sit here and just say like nick mullens
is better than jimmy garoppolo if that's
what you're trying to egg me on to say
or do anything like that i'm not trying
to no i'm just trying to say do you ride
with the hot hand and do you let jimmy
garoppolo get to 100 so he has his full
mobility with no limitations high ankle
sprain takes six weeks to heal that's
all i'm saying yeah i'm trying to start
trouble
right now right the trouble comes later
right the trouble i mean look i've
evaluated as you go and see where it is
from there uh jim the the the shame of
it is jimmy g was playing great when he
got hurt against the jets i mean even
battling through that and all that he
looked sharp um so that should at least
leave a good memory and shanahan and the
coaching staff's you know brain there
but yeah there's no rush if nick mullens
plays the way he did last week
the back half of the power rankings
17-32 has three of the nfc east teams
washington at 24. the eagles at 26 the
giants at 31. the cowboys just on the
other side of that graphic at 15 they're
one and two
washington's one and two philly's oh two
and one the giants owe in three
i think that the cowboys are in the
driver's seat in that division even
though they've lost two games they could
have won both of the games they lost
they arguably should have won the first
game of the season against the rams yeah
they have played a tough schedule right
they they yeah yeah the falcons aren't a
tough team but it was a tough game to
come from behind and win it yeah i think
the cowboys are clearly the best team in
that division do you agree i agree i do
i i do i i don't care that they're one
and two it means nothing to me you're
right i mean the rams and the seahawks
are good i i wouldn't you know the
cowboys could get another crack of both
of those teams in the playoffs i mean
their playoff caliber teams the way it
looks right now and the falcons game i
think you could still say there's a lot
of good things about it for the dallas
team i mean dallas yeah they messed that
game up early they did i mean gosh three
turnovers right to start the game you
know the falcons had the short field
five times and they only let up three
you know two touchdowns and the rest
were field goals so there's things to
build off they got a chance right now i
mean they got the browns this week we
know that'll be a pretty good test
that's two talented teams on the field
together then the giants the cardinals
the washington football team and the
philadelphia eagles their schedule sets
up for them to go on a run here and
we'll see where that does go um
they're interesting mike i mean to me
it's like a changing team i'm not so
sure they're not going to go seattle
mode here too
because i don't think their offensive
line is dominant anymore those days are
done they're not going to just run the
ball control the clock you know and then
like have and have a good defense to go
with it like we saw in 2014 or 2016.
that i don't think they're capable of
that
they got to go greatest show on turf and
i don't think their defense is good
enough to slow a lot of good offenses
down either to where you're going to be
able to play like ball control style
football i think they almost have to go
seattle mode to a degree and just let it
fly and put pressure on teams with their
offense and all the great weapons they
got on that side of the ball
the cowboys have the second best odds to
win their division according to points
bet minus 271 you bet 271 to win a
hundred the only other team with better
odds to win the chiefs at minus 1667 i
mean basically give them the crown right
now after what we've seen from them and
after what we haven't seen from the
raiders the chargers and the broncos
although the chargers did push the the
chiefs to overtime so uh you know
there's still some tough games there
then as we said yesterday the only way
you're gonna beat the chiefs is if it's
in a game where they don't have their
full focus when they have their full
focus they are very hard to beat yeah
the cardinals apparently didn't have
their full focus on sunday chris they're
at number 17 after losing to the lions
my concern with the cardinals is this if
you're a good team if you're breaking
into that category of the upper half of
the league on your way to the upper
echelon or echelons as the case may be
you beat the teams you're supposed to
beat you don't lose to the lions that's
to me always a mark of a team that is
truly among the best the best teams show
up and win
every week against the teams they're
supposed to be you know you're going to
maybe if you're lucky split the games
with the teams you're not supposed to
beat
you need to win the games that you can
put in that easy w column or your season
goes sideways quickly no i i mean you're
right there's no doubt about that
you are um
i i still think there's a lot of things
to be positive about with the arizona
football team though i i do think that
you know they they they kind of blew it
you know one of the reasons they blew it
and they played a team that matches up
with pretty well with their style of
football you know i think between you
know matt patricia coming from new
england and like the old story of you
know belichick struggled with mobile
quarterbacks right well you know the
last few years of patricia being in new
england and belichick they figured out a
pretty good formula to you know beat
patrick mahomes twice in the same year
and things like that to start stopping
these type of quarterbacks from taking
over the game and
murray was attacked in that game i think
differently than probably he ever was in
his career other than maybe playing
detroit last year they're phenomenal at
keeping you in the pocket doing all
those things they never really let
murray run the whole day he had two
scrambles and that was it and he's been
electric doing that the first two weeks
before that uh and then murray made
three you know bad interceptions that he
usually doesn't make so they had a
chance certainly to win that game uh
they did he made mistakes and i think
they played a team that was desperate
and all that
either way i'm saying if there's a loss
that you can deal with or at least i
look at as a guy that's talking on tv
with you i go there were some things
that i liked about that loss and the way
that cardinals team looks like they're
for real i don't think they're like
going to melt away or disappear from
this playoff conversation from the what
i've seen in three weeks i think they're
going to hang around all year long and
be a player in this nfc as we go
yeah i i agree and i hope that's the
case just because i think calamari is
spectacular the team needs to have a
higher profile and i want to see what
they do in the playoffs against the best
teams in the conference and we've
already seen what they did at san
francisco
the rams twice and we're going to see
them coming up against the seahawks
twice and before that week six monday
night game against the dallas cowboys
that would be a great one good ones the
browns are at number 18. and i remember
after that first
game loss to the ravens 38 to 6 and all
the dysfunction i dropped them down to
32 just to prove a point they're now up
to 18. they've won two in a row has
something fundamentally changed about
the team or are they just fortunate
they've played a couple of teams that
aren't that great chris well
yes but i i think we've seen some change
uh and you know i think we've talked
about it a lot and it's something that
we both sat there and kind of banged the
table about after week one that we
wanted to see
and we've seen it two weeks in a row
which is
stop worrying about you know the
headlines or the the the letters and the
big lights you know oh the stars the
passing game mayfield odell jarvis
landry damn it cleveland the best thing
you do is run the ball and nick chubb is
arguably the best running back in
football we've seen them two weeks in a
row play through the run
and they're a more effective football
team that way it helps their defense you
know it helps baker mayfield and i think
you know eventually it's going to help
that passing game too to kind of take
that next step to where we saw we have a
game where we're gonna go whoa there's
the passing offense it clicked so uh
they're they're one of those teams here
where it's like not sure about them like
the cardinals a little but there's
things i see about them i like and i'm
starting to go
all right i'm not saying they're going
to the playoffs but they're starting to
look like they could be a team that can
be in that conversation not quite as
confident as i am with the cardinals but
i think things are going in the right
direction
stick with a run stick with a run stick
with the run and that is the key and
that game against washington it really
wasn't an overpowering final score
suggested a bigger margin it felt like
the browns were in control all day long
but but you know
the browns of a year or two ago
maybe last year specifically found a way
to crumble right find a way to screw it
up right get get get frustrated because
we feel like we're out playing this team
but it's not showing up on the
scoreboard they just continue to go
about their business and here they are
at two and one all right we're going to
take a break when we return our draft
for
this wednesday edition of pft live the
best weapons non-quarterbacks the best
weapons through three weeks in the nfl
let's shine a spotlight on the guys who
are getting it done without taking the
snaps on every player
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports